waste no time i will ask the governance
officer to read out the domestic
arrangements and the fire regulations
for you
thank you chair
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
sitting down or if you exempt from doing
so and that you use the hand sanitizer
and wipes provided
please use the microphone sorry please
ensure the microphones are turned off
when not in use please do not interrupt
other speakers or hold separate
conversations while others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave please
ensure your mobile phones are on silent
or switched off
we will be using e-boating for this
meeting on the modern gov app so please
good members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
fire safety arrangements if you hear the
alarm leave the building immediately via
a fire exit and make your way to the
assembly point ipswich town football
ground follow the signs directing you to
the fire exits at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium
if you are in the atrium at the time of
the alarm follow the signs to the
nearest fire exit use the stairs not the
lifts do not re-enter the building until
it is told it is safe to do so
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to consent to
being recorded by entering this meeting
as a speaker you are also consenting to
being recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
thank you claire
quick introductions today our area
planning manager is john patman gee
legal advisor he's in to pray
our case officers sarah scott and owen
affairs
and governance officers claire philpott
you've already moved met
let's move on to the agenda
do we have any apologies for absence
chair we have apologies from councillor
mary mclaren thank you
any declarations of interest
nope
we have had the meet the minutes for the
last meeting
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these moves
councilor parker
thank you chad um i'll just um if i can
just draw attention chair um
with regards to the minutes on page five
at the very top 69.1
um i think this might
i suspect it's just an accuracy issue
but we've got the applicant shown there
as mr theodore bird um now that might
well be the case but as we have an
applicant mr theodore bird with us uh
this morning um i'm just wondering if
that might have been a cut and paste
issue possibly i wonder if we get some
clarification
thank you i will just have a look back
at the original
um
documents for that meeting and see what
i can see
um
yes apologies that should be the
applicant as hills
building group
i'll correct that for you thank you
thank you
okay
thank you i think we've resolved the
problem
subject to that change okay
subject to that change can i have a
proposal please
counselor parker secretary councillor
i now ask claire to arrange the
electronic
thank you chair members if you go to
your app and select the plus sign in the
top right hand corner
this boat is now in progress
thank you chair that's nine votes for
and one abstention that's carried
thank you very much
moving on
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
speed
thank you chair we have received a valid
petition with 233 signatures
the supporting statement as as follows
we the undersigned petition the council
we would like the planning committee to
reject the plans in application
dc2103644
to convert the ground floor cyclist in
bellingdon into a shop private flat
our local community has always had
somewhere to come together this is our
last chance to keep something
the current owners of the building have
been granted permission to convert the
upstairs into private flats and build
homes in the garden but this latest
application goes too far removing more
of the space from the community forever
we feel this is just a plan to
eventually convert the entire building
to private residential use
the change to a shop also could impact
on our much love convenience store
strawberry stores the venue has been
central to forming a sense of community
in recent years and should not be lost
we feel the venue can be made to be
profitable and would be interested in
running it as a community project
thank you chad
thank you
noted moving on
site inspections
are there any requests for site visits
okay
moving on then
planning schedule pl 21 19 we have
dc 2103643
53 bunnington street
i must ask councillors are you going to
stay on the committee or are you going
to speak as a ward member
i'm going to stay um on the committee
thank you
thank you very much
i will now
invite the case officer sarah scott to
introduce the application to the
committee thank you sarah
thank you chair good morning members
i'd like to present a full planning
application and list of building consent
for works in association with
the change of use from cafe to part
retail part office at ground floor
change of use of the disused ancillary
seller to commercial use and associated
works
and both works and change of use of the
shed to holiday let
at 53 ballingdon street sudbury formerly
the cyclist and prior to that the king's
head
this is brought before committee due to
its controversial nature
so this slide shows you the aerial views
of the site
as they're hatched in pink
again a site location plan edged in red
here you can see the site
it's a listed building it's surrounded
by other listed buildings
within the conservation area
okay is that better
okay
um
okay so the site is within the
conservation area it's a listed building
surrounded by other listed buildings
this is the proposed and existing
plans and elevations
the only addition to the external of the
building is this area here which is a
small lean to
which will go over the rear of the
building and the cellar area
this is
building a which is the shed which will
be converted
into the holiday lab
there is an area on the boundary just
here that you will notice is is it has
been opened more to allow for the
visibility display this was approved um
with the previous application
for
the conversion here the addition of
these two dwellings at the back of the
site
there are internal arrangements
to allow for the office
to go on this side of the building
um our heritage team are happy with the
internal changes
so this slide shows you the proposed
elevations of the outbuilding which will
be holiday accommodation
the shed currently has pitched roof
but originally it had a gambrill style
roof this design has been proposed which
allows for a first floor to be added to
accommodate a bedroom
windows have been limited to protect
neighbouring residential amenity
this is the rear of the main building
this slide shows the access to the
cellar and the area in which the lean-to
extension is to be located
this is the shed and the proposed
holiday let
which is left
of the rear of the main building
this shows the access point
onto
ballington road where the traffic lights
are
this is an area of wall
also beside the access which will be
removed to allow for the visibility
spray
this shows the
building that as existing which will be
removed to allow for
the two
a semi-detached um
two dwellings at the back of the plot
this is a google image just to show the
site from from the roadway you can see
the wall that
encloses the site
and then you see the rear of the
building and
you can just see the top of the holiday
lay
just here
and just to summarize counsellors are
asked to consider the change of use from
shed to holiday accommodation and
associated works
the works to the main building is
required to facilitate internal changes
and the lean to extension to the rear
over the cellar steps
all other changes of use are considered
permitted development under class e of
the use class order first of september
2020 that recently engaged in 2021
and in the last couple of months to
replace a number of other classes
including retail and offices
it is appreciated that this recent
change in legislation may have confused
the public in respect of this proposal
the works themselves are not considered
to harm the character of the listed
building and the change of use for just
the holiday let is considered
supportable in this sustainable town
location
therefore based on its merits approval
is recommended
thank you
thank you sarah any questions from
members
come to our own
thank you
on slide 13 can you tell us how much of
a wall they're taking down please
okay um i was looking at the approved
plans
and
i believe it will be around about here
so it allows for the building to be um
built in this position and one parking
space
um so yeah i believe it's around about
this point here
can't sit there
right
um
yes the
it's the former pub area car park isn't
it and um
certainly recently
um
there's does seem to be a lot of traffic
coming down north street uh sorry coming
down bamden hill
um if you're taking all this wall out
is there going to be more of a
restricted area
there for vehicles getting in and out
because it's quite congested now but i
think it's fair to bear in mind that it
was a pub car park so there was a lot
more cars going in the mount but i don't
think there was so much congested
traffic
um
getting um lined up at the traffic
lights in the past as there is now
okay um one of the slides um
thank you
oh there it is
so if you can see um
there are one two three five parking
spaces along here and the rest go along
the front of these build these buildings
here
the access point
i must just confirm was approved under
the previous planning application
um to have that wall removed
um
so no parking spaces will be lost due to
the loss of the the wall i hope that
answers your question
any more questions
that's right
thank you mr chairman i think it's
slide seven
no eight
yeah uh that win that french doors is
that proposed to be kept
and if so
how are you going to secure access into
the cellar if
those
seller doors are opened at any time
somebody drops through them
um i think that could be a question for
the applicant um let me just bring this
up
i don't really see too clearly but um
there will be a door here it looks
slightly further over from the cellar
door
where i believe stairs will be included
so hopefully that would prevent people
from falling down
just the second one the buildings at the
bottom of that particular slide
the
i think two
two-bedroom
houses or something
um are they part of this proposal or
have they been approved or are they just
sort of in somebody's dream
okay those have been previously approved
back in 2019
any more questions
yeah thank you mr chairman just um a
clarification please can you
can you show me that
the slide you head up already
that area on the left there by
the that yeah where your is there what
actually is that going to be
building a
this is whatever building is that
that is currently a shed that will be a
holiday let a single bedroom holiday
a
the question of the doorway in the
staircase i apologize we can't zoom in
on that particular plan but just to
clarify that the new extension on the
end
will have a double door you'll have a
space the stairs then go down to the
cellar but the doorway will be converted
the existing door into a single doorway
to one side so you'll be able to go
maneuver around so essentially you're
creating a new lobby
area uh where that extension at the end
of the um
the seller is at the moment so you'll be
able to choose which direction you go
down either down the stairs or around
the stairs and through into the building
just to clarify that because if it was
overly clear without drawing i do
apologize thank you
any further questions
if not thank you very much sarah
we'll move on
public speakers we have nobody from the
town council objector or supporter but
we do have the applicant mr theo bird
you have three minutes to address the
committee
uh good morning
chair and members my name is theo bird
and i'm the applicant
the scheme before you is about ensuring
the financial sustainability of the site
and the businesses within it in an ever
more challenging market
since we began regenerating the site the
main business the cyclist
has been lost leading
any chance of moving into profit
generating territory were dashed by the
pandemic
we therefore need to create a more
stable and sustainable financial model
for the business
not just so that it can survive but so
that it can thrive
i would like to suggest respectfully
that the application is a no-brainer
as your officer has pointed out the part
change of use to official retail doesn't
actually require planning permission it
is permitted development
the officer and all your consultees have
confirmed that the proposals are called
with the development plan and would not
give rise to any impacts including to
highways and residential immunity
the proposed retail space will provide
amenities that will cater for the local
population ballingdon and sudbury
the proposals will increase the amount
of immunity retail and employment space
we can offer and will decrease the rents
we need to charge and as a result they
will secure an uplift in employment from
three part-time roles to four full-time
ones
when we purchase the site we hope to
create a sustainable food and drink
destination for the locality and beyond
serving the area and drawing people in
from further afield
we have partially succeeded in our goal
we have with a dedicated following
amongst the ever-growing cohort of
london and east anglian cyclists
but we want to go further
i am passionate about seeing this part
of sudbury thrive
when i visit other places at home and
abroad and see the contribution that
their independent businesses make it
makes me want the same for ballingdon
why shouldn't we be able to create that
same draw to drive our local economic
growth and provide the inspiration and
impetus
for other exciting independent business
startups
i want ballington to be the best it can
be for its local population and for
those who visit the area to encourage
them and reward them for coming
i would be grateful for your support
today so that i can continue to deliver
this vision thank you thank you
you'll please wait there we'll see if
there's any questions any questions on
them thanks for the beer
um yes thank you could you just clarify
right at the start of your comments you
said something about the cyclist um and
lost leaders or something i didn't quite
get what you meant or i don't think i
really heard it because it was very
early on
that's okay so we
bought the pub
and then um
we've run the cyclist cafe and it's been
open for two years
so that has been the main business so
far on the site
but that's not a lost leader
it has been a lost leader that that was
what i thought yeah
yeah and that's disappointing to hear
that but um no problem i understand
where you come from now thank you
councillor parker
thank you
morning mr bird um
forgive me
what what is the
plans
for the converted offices well you
mentioned employment opportunities and
things
are you going to be running a business
from there or will it be sort of shared
office space or something
so
the idea is to divide the ground floor
space and on one side have an office and
on the other
um we want a
retail stroke cafe space
we've got someone lined up to go in um
and
it suits it it's sort of now we know the
site we we it will suit the site
council busby first
thank you chair um
but how do you respond to the
petitioners
i could i can see where they where
they're coming from
but it's it's just
when we bought the site um it was a very
it was a
an effectively an insolvent pub
um i know there's a lot of romance about
the good old days and you know back to
the pub but it's it's just not on the
cards we we gave it a go
by incorporating some licensed trade
within our cafe offering even then you
know we've done the statistics to make
that place successful as a pub you need
to sell 70 000 pints a year
or that's 15 kegs of beer a week
the license side of the cafe trade we
struggled to sell half a keg so i think
there's a massive gap between the
aspiration the petition
and and the reality and and i understand
but it's just we've we've been on the
coal face so we we really know what's
going on
thank you
councilman carol i hope yours is to deal
with planning matters unlike councillor
bless me
boy
i am not entirely certain but if i ask
the question you can rule it in or out
of order and it concerns the use of the
building which i think would be a
planning matter as i understand it and i
just wanted to confirm this the
intention is to continue use
as a cafe which it has currently been
for the last two years years i mean it
just says shop but we're not actually
defining necessarily exactly what that
shop will be as far as i can see from
the application that's the only app
reference i can hear to the word cafe
has been made just now by you mr bird is
that is that correct am i understanding
it properly
so we've got someone lined up uh to go
into the cafe jesus nature
of the um
of the petition and online activity we
we have to protect our client they want
it to remain confidential so it's the
sort of sad side of
you know obviously we're very keen to
share and and and evangelize about what
we want to do but then we've got to
protect our client from barrage of of
social media um
there will be a cafe offering within
that but it will be a sort of more
modern offering of probably a mix of
retail
and
um and a cafe offering which is quite
contemporary
thank you
council reyes
thank you chair um
welcome um can i ask
with the um employment opportunities is
there any likelihood of any
apprenticeships to help the youth
very likely so yeah even we in fact
we've got two plans uh for incoming
business um
so if the first one fails we have a
secondary plan both will feature
probably a cafe offering both offer very
exciting um
apprentice opportunities
councillor parker
uh yeah thank you um
we're just coming back to council
busby's non-planning matter where
communities uh might be concerned at the
loss of of an asset such as public house
they might often register
an acv be an asset of community value
has has any such bid come forward from
any group for
what is formerly the king's head
no
mario
thank you um just to pick up on that i
appreciate
the description of development perhaps
wasn't the best way of wording this
application and we apologize for that
but ultimately
the starting point here is this is a
cafe
and because of the recent changes in
legislation we now have this new class e
which is essentially combined all of you
know class a class b1 a bit of d1 all
into one
bulky class of its own so essentially
cafe is now the same class as a retail
shop which is the same class as a well
apparently according to this a swimming
pool ice skating rink professional
services nurseries and it also includes
b1 office use so all of that now is all
part of the same class it's all part of
the same family
so essentially
this is a cafe
the public house went some time ago it's
no longer a public house the legal point
to start from is a cafe
and therefore it can pretty much become
anything it likes without our
involvement anymore due to these changes
in legislation
in terms of office retail cafe and what
proportion the building has for those
different uses is up to the owner
in terms of this application before us
the only change of this element that
we're in control of is the change of use
of the shared to holiday let which is at
the back
uh as shown on the screen the only other
thing we have before us is works in
association with those change views in
terms of the planning that's the
extension and in terms of the list of
building that's everything including the
internal changes
so it's the physical works and just the
change of use of the holiday left
just didn't want us to go down a couple
of red herrings or paths thank you
thank you
can can i have council jameson
thank you
uh you mentioned that you're you're keen
to see this area of um sudbury
thrive and you feel this will make
that difference and it's wonder what
makes you believe that these changes
will
help the area thrive where you failed
previously
it's just really sort of understanding
we kind of understand the site now it's
because of the location it doesn't have
town send to draw
but it will have it does have a kind of
the commercial space is a space where we
can do
something in there um probably lower
footfall but if it
but if those are cash generative and
employ people then that in its own way
will make the area thrive it's a kind of
ballington is a kind of lower b end of
sudbury um it's not north street you're
not going to get lots of people um
buzzing around um in the same way they
do in the town center but it's but it's
it's so that it can thrive in its own
way so it'll be activities
within the building um that will employ
people and then there'll be a bit of
coming and going but that in my you know
to be honest
when we bought the site uh it was a
derelict pub we had an old guinness
smashed against the sign with bro you
know look it looked derelict
so i think that's you know and that's
what we're very proud of is that we've
lifted it thus far and it just you know
needs a little bit uh you know this
scheme will help us to sort of you know
put a sustainable uh longer-term
uh offer into the site that will be
there in the future
the last thing we want is to is to get
rid of all commercial activity on that
site so um you know i've said that in
the application as well
does that answer your question
i spear did you have another question or
you all right no no i've got a question
i've got a question also that i should
put in debate to the officers regarding
the petition but i'll come to that then
um and that reflects my next point um
if we were minded
not to approve this
what
um what is the alternative you see is
the situation there and i do know the
site very very well and certainly
from a pub point of view it's now in the
wrong place for today's modern sort of
world
but anyway that's
how do you see the alternative if we
were minded not to approve this
so
if if we didn't get this application and
for whatever reason we we didn't move it
forwards
i think it's you know it because it
switches into our worst case thing which
is that we will probably enter a program
um of of converting the whole site to
residential um the bits and pieces of
residential that we've done there you
know in its own way it works there's a
there's a market for affordable
rent for young people and things on that
site so we we could be confident in that
but we'd be very you know we'd be gutted
ourselves you know if that's what it
ended up being we don't think that
the bit that we want to major on
commercially on the site is right next
to a busy road yes someone would
probably live there if it was put on the
market is it a happy place to live no
thank you thank you
any more questions for the applicant
thank you thank you very much
moving on
um
we'll move into debate there's no more
questions and
i have to ask councillors as the board
member you you can start the debate you
don't have to it's not compulsory
you can have the last word
yes thank you um
i too know the site very very well and
ballingdon
um and
there are other places because i know
one of the um petitions against there's
no other place but
just up the road all saints church hall
has just been refurbished so that is a
community space with the kitchen and
everything and just around the corner is
afc sudbury so there are other places
where people could go um against that
argument
we desperately do need holiday let's
because i'm in and out of town hall and
i know how many people go in there and
look for them so that's something we
need and more employment so i would
just like to add that to it thank you
thank you
thank you
yes could i just be reminded by the
officers what was the corrupts of the
petition
were they against
and how sizable was it
were they against the
alteration
um to a cafe or are they against more
congested traffic there or what are what
are the reasons
well if i can sum it up quickly from my
copy here it's they want the venue to be
a community project um and
i can't see anything else that they're
really objecting to
other than they want to keep it as a
community asset
council buzzfeed
well in line with that um i'm surprised
that out of 233 people and not one of
them significantly objects against it to
turn up and speak against it so
it's a shame really isn't it
thank you
fashion for all
ask chair if we're in debate as yet we
are in that case i'm just looking
through everything and hearing
everything both from the applicant and
the officer
the only bit of this that is under our
direct control is the holiday let
everything else is already contained
within the um
the existing planning permissions and
permitted development rights so
effectively the question i ask myself is
would we grant the holiday let in any
other circumstances in a similar
location
um is the impact of that holiday let's
so great that there's any reason to
refuse i can't see that that's the case
and in both cases for this application
and the change of use i believe that the
the application
fits the bill i mean there is a need for
holiday lets in all these places
there is the possibility of continued
use i mean i have actually used that pub
ironically
to watch a cycle race
which went up bellington hill i think in
2015 the tour of britain went up that
hill and i went to that pub on the
corner and watched the race from there
they became a cyclist cafe so putting
that aside i'm proposed i'm proposing to
propose that we accept the officer
recommendation
on this motion
yes mr chairman i'm not proposing to
jump on my bike and go down there i'd
rather jump into your car and go down
there but uh um yes i think this is the
right course of action um holiday letter
is useful as clinton ayers has said and
i agree with the proposal so very
pleased to sector thank you
okay
any more comments council hint you want
to make a comment yes mr chairman just
point to clarify really
asset of community value has been
mentioned
but that only becomes valid even if it
is
listed as an asset of community value if
it comes up for sale
there's no proposals here to sell it
the proposal is to convert it into a
viable uh commercial activity
you're right
anything else
if not
we'll move to a vote on this thing
you just sort of summarize exactly what
we're i don't there's any any change
from what's been recommended by the
officer is there
so you're voting on the planning
application first in terms of the
recommendation before you i believe we
need to go through the process again for
the listed building application because
the applicant is
thank you uh so in terms of that uh the
planning application it is azure papers
um which is to re to grant planning
permission uh subject to the conditions
laid out there i'll talk about the
conditions so you've got the standards
time limit approved plans uh the
heritage conditions the highway
conditions uh holiday let occupation
construction hours and to be
imposed and lighting scheme to be agreed
thank you
we're now all set to do the electronic
vote
i can see that if you'd like to vote
members that vote is now in progress
okay
thank you members chair that's nine
votes four and one against that's
carried thank you very much
okay moving on
same side
dc 20 036 444 53 bunnington street
and this is for listed building approval
sarah were you going to say anything
else or you said it all in your first
presentation
i covered it all in the first
presentation thank you you've heard the
presentation
any questions from members on this
matter or you're all
happy to accept it
john
apologies um just in terms of your
recommendation on page 26 um it does say
our recommendation is to grant list to
building consent just under the
time of the standard time limit it is a
standard time limit for list of building
consent which is three years please
ignore the rest that's in that bracket
that shouldn't be there and we apologize
for that error
[Music]
comment uh yes i'll move the officer's
recommendation because we've heard it
all thank you
did the applicant want to speak on this
or just fine i didn't think he would
and council mcgraw you wanted to say
something i just said when i made the
first proposal i was quite prepared to
support the second but obviously that
was premature so the proposal in a
second
any more comments in the debate
if not we'll move straight to the road
thank you chair members i've just added
a note to uh reflect what our
mr paintman g has said
and that vote is now in progress
it's not sure
it's unusual for them to be ahead of you
claire
all right there we are
mr chairman what was the note that
you've added sorry
thank you members chair that's nine
votes four and one against that's
carried thank you very much indeed thank
you
thank you mr bird thank you sarah
right members
i propose to
move on to the next one straight away
unless anybody's desperate for a break
pop cancel the buzz because he was
always desperate for a coffee
sorry
i know i mean
that's why i was trying to get kingston
chair do you not think we should have
had a site visit for this one
you sure you want to go to acting again
why don't you ask councillor emma to go
around with the phone and
film it for you
you're quite within your rights to
suggest a site inspection as we discuss
this if you wish
okay
okay
dc2105221
genesis corner clay hall lane
an application
is before us because it is from a
councillor
right i will now make a case officer to
introduce the application to the
committee
[Music]
okay uh thank you chair good morning
members
today i'm presenting an application for
the erection of a front porch at genesis
corner in acton
as
the application has been brought forward
to the committee as it's been submitted
on behalf of councillor mabry
this is an aerial map of acton
the site as highlighted in red is
located to the east of clay hall lane
within the defined built up area
boundary of acton
so a closer view of the site which is
again highlighted in red
this is the site location plan
the site
the red line showing the application
site
in terms of constraints
the greater listed puddle.garden is
located to the norfolk site as shown in
gold
a group of protected trees on the tree
preservation order is located to the
frontage of the site to the west as
shown in green
and a definitive public right of way
runs along the southern and eastern
boundary of the site as shown in the
dashed green line
sorry before we move on can you just
explain the different greens is there a
grade one listed building to the north
and then
trees to the south or yes that's correct
um there is a great one listed to too
sorry
uh no that is a group of tree
preservation orders to the north side um
and along for eastern greece
all of it so we've got
tree preservation orders here
down here
and along here it
yeah it unhelpfully it's very square
shape those trees yeah at the top but
they are actually it's just the plotting
of where those trees are in a group uh
so it's a group tpo but it's done in a
square which makes it look like a
building but it it is that all the
greens are a tree a relative
uh tree pios okay
well if if acton have been able to
develop the ability to grow square trees
i think they should be listed as well
thank you council advisory
would you like to continue
um so i'll take you through the existing
and proposed plans
so visually existing and proposed site
layouts with the proposed port shown
to v western elevation
so
so here
so if you see existing floor plans again
the existing porch
can be seen here
of existing elevations so again you can
see the existing porch canopy
yeah
pose floor plans again
we can see the proposed porch
and finally to the post elevations
again clearly see the porch
post
the extension would be finished in cream
hardy plank above a red brick plinth and
a pantile roof the red brick plinth and
the pan tiles would match existing
dwelling
so now just a couple photos of the site
for some context
in the bottom left corner of the slides
shows where the photo was taken from
uh this year's the front western
elevation of the site
with this one the northern side
elevation again you can clearly see the
existing porch canopy
to summarize
the proposed extension is considered to
appear modest respecting the
relationship with the site with an
appropriate size and scale and
appearance
the proposal would have no detrimental
impact on highway safety or residential
immunity nor impact the character of the
surrounding area including the setting
of the greater listed building
and the proposal reported for relevant
development management policies and vmpf
therefore the recommendation therefore
is to grant parent permission of the
condition set up within your agenda
thank you
thank you owen
any questions to the officer
counselor beer
thank you mr chairman um perhaps i've
missed it but on slide
um
eight and ten
um and then you shoot twelve is the roof
yes is is the porch roof already
in existence so the extension bit is the
benefit
apologies uh essentially the existing
porch will extend out from the existing
kind of canopy area
so
if we can see from the proposed
elevations
uh you can
see so you've got the existing there so
you can see the existing yeah
yeah the existing canopy roof
and then from the pose it extends out
further
is that marginally higher that uh
elevation for the porch roof not like
worrying about it but is that the case
it looks slightly higher and slightly
further reaching
and um the eaves height will match
existing um
and the ridge height will measure four
meters
which
would match existing i believe it makes
it slightly higher
thank you
any more questions for the officer
if not we'll move into debate
did you have a question for the officer
i'm just going to ask whether he
considered it to be sustainable
thank you count supposedly oh you don't
have to answer
fine
but
is that the question councillor parker
no we just want to open up the bay
council hidden is yours a question
no mr chairman i'm just going to propose
that we accept the officer's
recommendation i think this wouldn't
have come to us except for two reasons
one listed building
uh
impact and two in fact it's a councillor
but the impact on the on the listed
building seems to be virtually nil
come to a bear do you want a second uh
yes mr chairman i'll be very pleased a
second that he wouldn't have come here
and hadn't been a counsellor um and
really we shouldn't be wasting any more
time we've done what we need to do and
i'm very pleased to send it thank you
counsellor and i tell you you were in
giant second as well
you're gonna have to home go home and
practice quick on the door like cancel a
beer
are there any more comments if not we
have
a proposal in front of us
to the officer's recommendation is the
area planner manager happy with that
more than happy so your recommendations
on page 34 simply a time limit condition
and approved plan standard stuff
fine in that case i think we'll ask
claire to open the vote thank you chair
members that vote is now in progress for
you
yes
thank you
thank you members chair that is ten
votes for that's you now
thank you
um
that's the final vote um the next
meeting will be in the elizabeth room
and on
the 1st of december
thank you i formally close the meeting
thank you